[Music]  I'm talking about granny Blake Shelton  and Gwen Stefani have no problem sharing  their love but the country singer  revealed something new to Ellen  DeGeneres telling her it's Gwen's  surprising normalness that has changed  his life and just a iOpener I mean to be  with somebody like her the voice coach  says Gwen's been famous for so long he  was surprised she's so grounded calling  her a quote good human being with a  great heart she's kind of like just a  homebody she's she loved her kids and  she's hot yeah you saying the singers  just spent a cozy Thanksgiving together  with Blake's family so yes they are  keeping things normal and getting more  and more serious  et spoke with when in November here's  what she said about her man it's  incredible to have a best friend like  that guy he's amazing  now I like being with her I just like  being with her but you know  [Music]